well it's interesting I mean you know
it's it's hard to talk about electric
cars these days without talking about
Elon Musk and and of course Tesla has
got a lot of attention as of late for
it's it's sort of disappointing results
early on in the Chinese market and
you've heard Elon Musk actually point
out the fact that you know one of the
things that's really holding them back
is this perception that charging is very
difficult in China including charging at
home Japan is not in that situation and
that's something that Nissan is really
trying to point out here 40,000 charging
points they say now in Japan which
eclipse is the number of gas stations
that you have in Japan it's definitely
the sort of number that really you know
kind of crystallizes the progress that's
been made early on to try and get
charging infrastructure up and running
in Japan and get these electric vehicles
selling it at greater numbers now tell
me something here this is nice on
research so there could be a lot of
skeptics out here as well and say that
it's just a well this I'm trying to
boost their leaf vehicle absolutely and
there's certainly some holes that it
could be poked in in these numbers you
know you're making a comparison here
between charging points and gas stations
that have several places to refuel
they're also counting in their number
the number of home charging points and
look this this still doesn't get to
another big concern if you're a buyer in
terms of how long it takes to recharge
regardless of how many options you have
in terms of where you can recharge so
that's still a challenge for the leaf
leaf and electric vehicles going forward